good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
now i can say happy hump day i got my
days confused yesterday
apologies happy hump day but don't
forget to hump someone you absolutely
love to
can you even say it if t-h-e-o is not
here
well you actually don't have to spell
t-h-e-o because we only do that
but i just want to elongate his name
well i have in his memory because i miss
him i'm right he didn't die
chill like a busy afternoon full of like
you know
like two things so i didn't want to like
drag theo along to all of that i
understand the reasoning as i always do
i'm wearing a blaster like i just missed
it i'm wearing a blazer too which is
just so
interesting i mean blazers are like the
thing you know well this is an
interesting blazer because it comes with
this sweater
built in and i wear this blazer outfit
because it's a whole outfit you know i
don't have to like even think about it
i wear it like once a year and i can
justify the space it takes up in my
closet that looks like it takes up a lot
of space it does
but it's like such a polished
professional look very like a beard
i feel like cameron wescott every time i
wear veronica beard because i feel like
she's
always wearing veronica beard well
i actually wore a dress by veronica
beard once and it made my fupa look so
big
that i've never forgiven veronica or her
beard
[Laughter]
i mean what can you do um well you can
move on with your life and deliver the
fast five and have a great show we have
an amazing show for you guys today
not only do we have the fast five we of
course have our
not out we're really jackie's recap of
the bachelorette because i was unable to
watch
spoiler alert worst episode ever oh wow
okay like so funny those are fighting
words
so boring i'm sorry like tasha did
nothing wrong she's a queen still the
truckers for tasha like might be on
hiatus today just because like they
weren't inspired by last night's episode
all of a sudden it's seven guys how many
home times hometowns are we going to
like more than four i'm so confused
because they keep saying the group for
hometown's not the four
oh interesting but maybe that was a vibe
only i was getting okay
and then third we have dear toasters
which is our advice segment and
we have an update from a girl who wrote
in i want to say like over a year ago
and she really kind of shook up the deer
toasters community and people have been
asking for an update on the girl who was
hiding water
well she saw her boss hiding water in
the basement or something boss is like
maybe like ross's family members so this
is
a nepotistic situation so there was a
lot of confusion as to what he was like
hiding supplies for and we have an
update from her so make sure to stay
tuned at the end of the show
for that but lots to do before that lots
to do before that i had just such a
torturous day yesterday i had
such a bad migraine on the show
yesterday i don't even remember what was
said what was done
just want to leave it in the past i went
home and i literally was like crying
because of the pain
crying it was so sad but sweet he was
crying
sweets was there beside me cuddled up
beside me like making it all better you
know cried like
no like and it's a very high tolerance
for pain the migraine was in my right
eye
like it was so so painful and i don't
know i
because our schedule was different
yesterday i thought maybe like i just
overslept so i was having a headache so
i didn't take my magical pill before the
show
big mistake huge like this morning i
woke up feeling off took my magical pill
good
feeling on oh so it's nice that you have
those pills though
it is nice but yesterday was just like
strike it from the calendar i had to
cancel my whole day
oh wow i like had big big plans turned
into big big bed
big big hands big big hands um no
yesterday my timing my biological clock
was off because
we recorded our show late you guys
remember for the olivia jade red table
talk interview to come out
and like my whole day was just like
disheveled as [ __ ]
it was disheveled i got home and it was
just like four o'clock and i'm like what
is it time for lunch i literally ate
lunch at 4 o'clock i made some amazing
pasta it was so good
oh yeah but i also caught up in the most
recent episode of the flight attendant
which really um cemented my belief that
no one needs to watch the show like i'm
already like five episodes in so i think
it's only six episodes like
i'm just gonna finish it but like it's
really bad like apparently it's based on
a book
oh is that true have you been seeing
that in the credits no i don't watch the
credits
so you know sometimes it says like based
on yeah no but like i i really
i've become such a whiz with my apple tv
remote like i skip intro skip credits
like i'm
i skipped the commercial like i'm such a
whiz i'm just like boom boom boom
like watching the intro not every time i
watch an episode
but like a lot of the times because i
feel like with every episode i start to
understand the intro more and more well
i thought that was going to happen with
the undoing like it is somehow
or like even with game of thrones like
the map was somehow telling you
something
but it didn't so i've never really
gotten an actual clue
from an intro yeah i don't know i just
i have no clues but i feel like i start
to understand the intro more the clues
are the show
that explain the intro yeah i guess just
so whatever it's just not a good show
like
you really don't have to watch it okay i
wasn't planning on it but like maybe i
might have
stumbled on it but if anyone in hbo's
listening like i'd love a prequel like
kaylee cuoco being a fabulous flight
attendant like being fun
and like drunk like that's what was the
best part the first 20 minutes of the
first episode and then it was just
terrible
damn yeah she was like meeting men all
over the world and like she was like
this fun
loving gal not for long not for long
we have an amazing show for you guys
today stick around to be seen i mean tbd
you never know how amazing the show is
going to be
honestly i don't want to jinx it i don't
want to jinx it
we've been on a roll like a hot streak
with just like premium content left
right center up
down can't be stopped so much laughter
yeah so much positive and what's so
crazy is like
the stories you guys there's literally
nothing out there
unless you're right here gets drunk how
tim mcgraw is decorating his christmas
tree like
oh how is he he's well he thinks his
wife's trying to kill him because he's
all the way at the top of the tree
ladder that's what i
gleaned from god that's what i gleaned
from the story i did not click on that
is
so dumb like right that's what i'm
saying you guys the stories are
worse than ever but it forces us to get
a little creative we've got some biz
news today
and you know what i just have to really
that article that you just
painted a picture for it really reminded
me like the holiday season is when
celebrity publishers publicists are just
working overtime like
check in on your friend if she's a
publicist because she's been working
really hard because like
i've been seeing so many like you have
to see vanessa hudgens christmas
decorations like who cares
who cares literally yeah you [ __ ]
character i just except i did see rachel
ray get emotional over her christmas
because there was a fire yeah her home
in upstate new york like completely
burned down that's so sad i know so i
actually that was some good pr work
i felt really bad for her well yeah i
don't know i just feel like everyone's
trying to hit their deliverables in
q4 always yeah but especially this year
and it shows so anyways i think without
further ado it's time to get into the
fast life stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and yes but would it be an episode of
the morning toast if we
oh sorry i'm dropping my cards oh my god
nerd alert sorry i just wanted something
alert i just want to stop that's so mean
so mean on wednesdays i have a lot of
cards because i have the dear toasters
in here too
and sometimes it's hard to maneuver my
god
keep the lights on in here but it
wouldn't be an episode of the morning
toast if it wasn't brought to you
by bruce and we were just before the
show talking about this hilarious bruce
commercial we saw with kevin hart and
it's like if it's good enough for kevin
hart's teeth like the biggest comedian
in the world
and claudia yes i'm claudia outright the
second biggest
in the world physically um then it's
good enough for you you guys okay
everything of the sort is what people
are saying about the brewster
the reviews are in and they're
everything of the sort
brushing your teeth can be a chore but
brushing them is fun and it's a hundred
times as effective
bruce delivers premier sonic wave
technology it is honestly one of the
best electric toothbrushes i've ever
used
but they don't have the markups that
some of the big electric toothbrushes
tack on so some electric toothbrushes
can cost over two hundred dollars bruce
is much more reasonably priced
and we have a coupon so if you want to
get one for yourself or as a gift for
the holiday season
you really can get a good price because
you can get 15 off your brush
which is already very reasonably priced
when you use the promo code toast
bruce dot com brucia spelled b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com you you can try it 90 days
risk-free and get a two-year warranty
that's bruce.com b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
promo code toast when you get the brush
kit which is what me and jackie both
have
we chose like the millennial pastel pink
which is really pretty
you get the electric toothbrush plus
three brush heads a magnetic charging
station
and a sleek travel case and the brush
comes with six cleaning modes
daily white gentle gum tongue and
the max mode it's really they just have
a mode for everything the battery life
stays up for
up to four weeks it's very cute it looks
great on your countertop and it works
really well so
oh and they give back so with every
brush
refill shipped bruce donates oral care
supplies through a reason to smile so
you can
feel good knowing that your purchase is
going a long way bruce.com
b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com promo code toast
love it okay first story a little
cinematic news okay
kourtney kardashian will appear in the
he's all that remake
starring addison ray you know i heard
about this and then also
this is a great um jumping off point to
the youtube video you sent me
yes okay but first courtney revealed
that she's joined the cast if he's all
that
which is a remake of the beloved 1999
film she's all that
the remake will be starring tic tac
personality and kardashian best friend
addison ray courtney posted a picture of
herself reading the script
saying studying at he's all that movie
and then addison commented on it work
partner
the official instagram account for the
movie revealed kardashian's character's
name is jessica miles torres
it's unclear what role she will be in i
feel like she's someone's like older
sister from college like you think
i feel like she's literally not even
gonna have well she had a script so
she'll have one line
right but i don't think she's gonna have
like an actual role so i have been
very positive about the kardashian
kourtney kardashian addison ray
friendship like
people on the internet have just been
like so mean like this is weird cheese
19 and chase fighting like i really
don't care
i i get the friendship i don't think
it's that weird but like this is taking
it like a little far
do you think this is what's taking him
it's a little weird i feel like if you
can get on board with the friendship
like this is just like friends working
together
which i support like i guess it's it's
it's nice of courtney because like this
is addison's first
date for your future film so courtney
like attaching her name to it in any way
is like a
sign of support in hollywood i think
it's like a it's a nice thing that you
do for someone
but i don't know something i've never
reported on news of them and like wanted
to be like their friendship is weird
but like this is starting to give me
like weird vibes oh this only gives me
weird vibes because like i
can't see kourtney kardashian as an
actress oh i mean she's actually
they've done over the years they have
dave they have cameoed in like a few
things the kardashians
it's never it's never it she i actually
watched that show dave because your
husband told me to watch it
and courtney was in it like three times
was she again
unmembered i just feel like they're
always playing kardashians like
yes she was playing herself oh then
that's good but she's not playing
herself here
oh is that for sure for sure the
instagram account for he's all that
revealed the name of her character oh
what was it again jessica miles torres
oh yeah that's true i guess i haven't
ever seen her act in anything where she
was playing a character she was always
playing herself
right that's what i'm saying so i don't
know this kind of like makes me feel
like the movie's
fake sort of yeah it's not like it's a
big blockbuster did you see last week
they like shut down union station
in l.a to film but it's a major coven
testing site and they got like all this
backlash
oh that's bad deservedly so yeah that's
bad
oh my god by the way things are really
happening speaking of covered like i
hate to even address and like say her
name here but
i went to dwayne reed today because i've
been like on this journey of trying new
seltzer
okay today i'm trying the polar lemon
stuff i love polar yeah the lemon is not
it it tastes like pine salt in a bottle
you just don't like lemon that's not
true because i love lemon lacroix and i
love
lemon bubbles coming for lemon no this
is just pine solid vibes
but i was in there today and they had a
sign on the window that said we don't
have the coven vaccine yet
like so people like i guess have been
coming in but like that means it's
coming it's coming i was
reading news reports as soon as this
weekend people in the u.s could start to
get it okay i want to say um
i saw a couple videos of like the first
people the first old woman in the uk and
i think
with her sweater they were so [ __ ]
cute like i wanted to cry did you see
that the second or one of the early
people in the uk who got his vaccine his
name was william shakespeare
shut the [ __ ] goes by bill no i didn't
see that
but those videos are so cute yeah no
really really cute it's so exciting
really quickly back to addison right
sorry that was like a derailment i just
love her so much and i'm so happy for
her
um but you sent me this youtube video
from her channel that she just put up it
was like the truth about
us very clickbaity but i guess it was
like the first time her and bryce since
they've rekindled their romance have
like
confirmed their relationship and i
thought like all week they've been
confirming with like their
sexy posts together i i didn't know it
was even up in the air like or up for
debate
right they did like a really like a
video that stressed me out on so many
levels it was q
a while we work out like what while we
work out in masks that are on our chin
the whole time like the
chat knee yeah the chuck knee my chin
was just take it off
my chin was sweating watching the video
like yeah i'm not even joking it was
giving me like so much chin anxiety and
they were like so fake working out
like yeah no like answer the questions
then work out
two could be two separate videos like it
was so much but anyways
let's get to the meat of the video which
was their relationship
being confirmed and like them just being
like so lovey-dovey
they're really into each other yeah i
guess i just
i i stand firmly in my belief that like
addison ray can do so much better on so
many levels i know but like the heart
wants what it wants and her heart wants
price
i mean she's
i was watching the video and i was like
this queen like yeah like
this this guy right but that's what the
queen chose
i guess but like i don't know i just i i
want more for her and maybe that's just
me having
really high expectations but also she's
so young like
just let i feel like let her do it
you know not like i'm not wishing that
they break up but like things change
over time people change like
she'll grow into whatever's meant to be
okay you know i just and she seemed
really happy yeah
okay whatever if you if you stand you
have to like stam
what makes you happy okay that's
probably true
you know i just i i stan addison
and i want her to be like as famous as
possible like i want her to just break
all the bounds of like
social media start i'm like i want all
this for her and i just want it all to
go right and i just i don't know if
bryce is like the place
is like where it's gonna happen one i
feel like it's all going right two i
feel like she needs to move at a speed
that is sustainable
yes and she she's well on her way like i
think this movie
he's all that he's all that he's all
that he's all that because the other one
is
yeah i'm like okay i think this movie
he's all that is going to be
a really big movie is it on a streaming
service like is it
i mean i think it might be theaters who
knows what what will be
when by the time it comes out but i
think it's going to be like super
popular and
big okay i'm hearing oscar buzz
oh please speaking of trailers you know
they're filming something on my block
and my doorman told me selena gomez was
right outside my building yesterday all
day because she's in the movie oh my
goodness or tv show i don't know what it
was check out her imdb find out what it
is maybe you could get a little cameo in
the background
yeah no i keep walking theo like near
the trailers i'm like maybe they're
going to need like an extra or something
like or like a perfect man yeah no
theo's like a real show
the lead yeah the lead guy or maybe like
i don't know the lead girl gets a dog i
don't know like theo could become a star
or they need a doctor on set right
there's a medical emergency
doctor so many potential opportunities
for theo
just keep walking him there you got it
yeah i think selena would love him
i concur i mean who who wouldn't who
wouldn't are you ready for our next
right little royal bed bed news yes i am
queen elizabeth's granddaughter zara
tyndall
is pregnant explain to me who she is in
the lineage i will
zara the daughter of princess anne you
know her from the crown
she's the one this is anne yeah she's
like so charlie's sister
yes exactly and the granddaughter of
queen elizabeth is expecting another
baby with her husband who is a retired
rugby pro named mike tindale that's so
cute what a cute little marriage
yeah she probably has like a good amount
of like balance in her life
wait not only is this royal babe news
but
the retired rugby star mike revealed the
pregnancy
in a new episode of his podcast the good
the bad and the rugby oh that's a great
podcast name first of all second of all
we love the medium getting the respect
it deserves
and i love the royals by the pa yeah the
podcasting industry like infiltrating
buckingham palace
i love to see it like the queen's
granddaughter is married to a podcaster
anything can happen you guys you guys
anything can happen
so it goes queenie vibe the lineage
queenie vibe
princess anne zara on the way but
they have um two daughters already mia
grace and lena elizabeth
wow this next little one will mark the
queen's ninth
great grandchild oh my god what legacy
she's left
what she's still here sorry yes what a
legacy period end of sentence
yes totally i just love a little royal
bad venues
and a little podcasting news to have the
rbn and the podcasting news like be
merged as one it doesn't happen ever
ever
it's never happened before historic
except actually when
kate was on podcasts like at the
beginning of quarantine
with like kate of william and kate yeah
i remember we reported that we were just
like excited for the royal podcast
crossover it really has been
not to get all sappy because it's
december it's been an amazing year for
the podcasting industry
yeah it really has been i would love to
see how many podcasts there were at the
end of 2019 versus how many at the end
of 2020 because literally
everyone has started a podcast from
famous people to non-famous people yes
you know i was out to dinner with my
friends and they were one of them
told me that his friends started a
podcast like just not for the sake of
like getting famous i'm like camera
light
but like just like for the sake for the
sake of like
having a passion i thought that was so
cool
um you're right everyone has a podcast
yeah no
it is cool it's a great it's a great
medium we can't stress it enough yes and
thanks for listening by the way
yeah thanks you there's so many out
there thank you for taking
choosing to spend your time with us yeah
we appreciate it no we really really do
especially as there are more and more
podcasts like it's so many to choose
from it's really an honor thank you
truly
okay next story a little carl lentz news
a little cln
yes there has been a lot of carl lens
news that like
if we picked up all the car lens news we
would literally be the morning car
lunch which honestly sounds like a great
show
and i'm not gonna lie at certain points
in time we have definitely been the
morning lunch
oh for sure but tyler perry has put a
hundred thousand dollars towards
paying karl lentz's la rent
what tyler perry dropped nearly a
hundred thousand dollars so disgraced
hillsong pastor carl
wow they went from calling him like
former pastor
disgraced my god disgraced king you got
laura lentz the media is so dramatic
like he didn't
kill anyone but like in for what he does
yes he has disgraced his family yeah i
guess and his church
okay by his moral failures that's true
and apparently there was more than one
there was that uh
audio if you're into the lens family
drama then there's so much
there's so much but tyler perry dropped
nearly a hundred thousand dollars so
carl luntz and his family could live in
a luxury la mansion the uk
son is reporting tyler perry covered six
months of rent
up front on the 5 000 square foot five
bedroom manhattan beach home
where lentz and his family moved after
unloading their new jersey home days
before he was sacked from the mega
church for infidelity
so that's the thing it's like when
you're part of these churches like
your whole life is paid for by the
church your home your car so when you
leave the church like you have
literally nowhere to go right but tyler
perry and carl lentz
are friends and tyler perry is helping
him during this difficult time that's
really nice i mean anytime we talk about
tyler perry on here it's usually about
his philanthropic efforts
and i'm just like so i just love him
yeah no
always constantly impressed by him and
this is just a nice thing for a friend
to do for another friend so is
is tyler perry a member of hillsong like
is that how he knows carl unclear
unclear i'm curious on the the yeah the
relationship the
the source says that tyler has been
friends with carl and his wife for years
and is sticking by them and their kids
during this difficult time so they might
just be friends
yeah outside of church wow i mean that's
just crazy
and i need friends like tyler perry you
know right because i could really use
six months
in a beach house like that's just i've
had a rough year like i need a beach
house and
i think tyler perry knows that yeah yeah
and also like your friends need to step
up to the plate
yeah no it's like none of my friends
have like ever gifted me six months of
rent in a beach house
and i just feel like i need to
reevaluate like my choices like to how i
got here like with this particular group
of friends and what hurts even more
is knowing that they probably won't even
hear this so [ __ ] true and you know i
am scheduled to see them this evening
so i might just bring it up like start
some drama i think you should come in
with a list of things
that you'd like to see from your friends
in the new year you're gonna see me
tomorrow i'm gonna be friendless as [ __ ]
okay are you ready for our next story
it's a little business a little ipo news
wait a little ipo news brought to you by
jenny kane is that the one
yes oh what a coincidence this is like
one of those coincidences we've been
talking about one of those like doubles
yeah
jenny kane believes in creating everyday
pieces that are made to last forever
polished basics and home pieces that
will never go out of style
jenny kane's secret to an effortless and
elevated home and wardrobe is timeless
classics
and inviting neutrals that focus on
comfort without sacrificing style
yes i actually have quite a few pieces
in my home by jenny kane are these
fabulous candles that smell
delicious but are just like the holsters
are so cute i'm almost done with one of
them i'm gonna hollow it out and like
make like a makeup jar or something
um and then i also have this fabulous
like nude cardigan that's just like so
taylor swift like
standing on her rhode island house
pacing the rocks staring out at the
midnight sea
yeah um the pieces from jenny kane are
like so stylish and so
basic but in a good way like yes because
i don't really dress like you're a fine
classic casual i have a white sweater
like this perfect shade of ivory that's
like the perfect winter white
and it's so comfy and so styling so soft
too
you can do both from wardrobe essentials
to everything that makes your space feel
like home
these are timeless pieces that everyone
will love their signature pieces are
their mules which come in leather suede
shearling and more
which is the classic shoe that started
it all they also have the chelsea and
canyon boots in leather suede oiled
leather and shearling
and their fishermen in cocoon from
cashmere to cotton they have fabulous
products for your feet for your body for
your home
check out jenny kane really if you're
looking to have like that curated like
mood like lauren elizabeth's style it's
like so neutral and so
like i've been really trying to like
make my home as like curated a vibe as
possible
and these timeless pieces from jenny
kane are really helping and if you're
looking for your forever pieces and you
want to get 20
off your first order use the code toast
at checkout
the website is jennycain.com the code is
toast for 20
off your first order and you can spell
jenny kane j e
n n i k a y n e dot com
promo code toast for 20 off your first
order check it out
okay ready for our ipo news yes who's
going public doordash
doordash is making its trading debut
wednesday after raising 3.37 billion
dollars in an initial public offering
with airbnb's ipo set to follow within
hours by the way i feel like doordash is
literally like the newest company like
we've had seamless and grubhub and
ubereats and postmates for so long
and i really only remember starting to
hear about doordash
at like revolve festival yeah like a
year ago maybe
two years ago at coachella i feel like
that was the first time i had heard of
it but maybe that's just because it
wasn't big in new york by the way that
is exactly where i first heard about it
you're right
at revolve festival look at revolve like
so
but bloomberg is saying the biggest u.s
food delivery company
doordash is part of a cadre of
consumer-facing web-based businesses
that have successfully navigated the
coronavirus pandemic and are expected to
go public
this month well so
let's what's the landscape of current
uber eats types of programs seamless and
grubhub are now
one yes uber eats is owned by uber
obviously
yes who owns postmates someone i think
bought it
postmates yeah they're they're um
they're all getting snatched up they're
monopolizing
yeah it's a monopoly which one do you
use the most i'm so
loyal to ubereats it's crazy it's last
night was uber eats but i feel like i
initially i just always assume post
mates is the best
but then i'm always let down like
they're always showing me the same three
restaurants and it's like there's got to
be more out there i concur i think
in new york i think postmates is the
worst app people in a layer are like i
post them into this i post many of that
and i think they use it in the way that
we use like ubereats or seamless because
there's nothing on postmates in new york
yeah
but postmates is still that only app and
i feel like this is what it started as
and now they've just gotten like so far
from what they were
like it used to be like i need anything
in this world duct tape
like please go to duane read for me and
i i still use it sometimes if i need
something like an emergency pharmacy
delivery
yes when i was in miami i postmated
advil to the restaurant
right uber eats doesn't do like pharmacy
deliveries like that well uber
gas station or grow now they do grocery
yes yes uber now has groceries
but uber when like a few years ago used
to have a service called uber rush
and that was absolutely everything of
the store it was truly just a messenger
service
so if you know like i remember being
downtown at dinner and i realized i left
my license
uptown ben put my license like in an
envelope in a bag
left it with our doorman and you could
pay someone like 10 bucks
usually on a bicycle to just shuffle
items back and forth
and i guess it wasn't that popular
because they got rid of it like shortly
after it launched
but i just want i want to go on record
saying like i was the number one
customer for uber rush because i was
like always leaving my things everywhere
yeah and i just loved uber rush so much
and just like the premise of like a
career service
yeah no but i guess it wasn't it wasn't
lucrative no not like food delivery
especially this year before delivery is
booming and
apparently doordash is the best in the
biz so congratulations on their ipo
and you know what's so funny like when
we first when we were podcasting in the
beginning of quarantine
saying how we haven't been ordering in
so much like we've been cooking so much
and i really want that to like stay i'm
like fully back on my ordering and like
three times a day grind and i have no
regrets
yeah i need to go back like swing back
the other way a little bit
but it was hard to maintain it was i do
feel like i'm better than i was like
this time last year yeah but i i have
gone back to ordering like what are we
going to order tonight
no i know like not like what am i going
to make yeah and i'm no longer like
hoarding kosher meat in my freezer like
i'm just
yeah my friends got really backed up for
a while like i ran out of freezer space
yes
so i have to start ordering it i'm like
fully traumatized by my [ __ ] freezer
like
but there's just like so much action and
like you have to like it's tetris
yeah it's tetris like this one
it's [ __ ] tetris like trying to make
like the popsicles and it's just
something weird about like having your
ice cream next to rummy like i'm really
like
over my freezer and just like
conceptually i need multiple freezers
like
one for meat products one for dairy
products i just think it's gross one for
liquor
oh my god so much yeah the jugs
um so actually i was having freezer
fatigue as well for the last few months
and when we moved we had to go
we had to bring the freezer items to the
new apartment and so it forced us to go
through
everything and now like my freezer game
oh really on point
there's just like literally stuff in my
freezer put another thing in it
wow i can't there's literally things in
my freezer that have been there like
since i moved in and i don't know why
i'm like sentimental
and by the way i also keep like my jade
roller and my ice roller in there it's
just disgusting in the fridge
no freezer i find that it doesn't hold
any coldness
when it's in the fridge oh i keep mine
in the fridge and i already feel like
they're so cold
mind you the only time i've used it is
when i was carrying my fridge items to
my new apartment
so i saw it at the top of the bag and i
was like this feels good
no because the one time i used a jade
roller i went too hard in the middle of
my head and i gave myself a migraine and
you know
you never forget i don't know if i would
blame the jade roller here but no no i'm
just saying like why would i put myself
in that situation again when
realistically jade roller doesn't do
[ __ ] sure sure like i've seen everyone
who uses a jade roller you look the same
before and after sorry i said it
it's one of the truest things you've
ever said except i have been on
my ice roller game for like de-puffing
and there is there is magic in ice yes
because like ice is like one of those
elements of the earth that's like puffs
has a purpose yes like i guess jade and
rose quartz are elements of the earth
yeah but your jade roller for 11 on
amazon doesn't have real jv here's the
thing the best thing about the jade
roller
is the fact that it's cold so just use
an ice roller and the ice roller is so
much bigger and it feels so good
so good when you have a migraine and you
rub that ice roller over your eyes it's
there's bellissima nothing like it
okay ready for our fifth and final story
it's a little tech news a little tn
i'm being so annoying sorry yeah like
because
i just like i love when you do it when
it's like so good like right like sad
royal news soil news srn
yeah but like tech news we could just
say tech news yeah like some interesting
chess news would you consider it biz
news or no no you know i wouldn't
because i really think
it's tech okay and i think you'll feel
the same way once i tell you finally
what it is
this is such a robust um and really
nothing happened in the celebrity worlds
in the last 24 hours
yeah no we go in waves of like a
branching out of the celeb world i just
have to say i love talking about like
biz and tech news
um so lay it on me apple has new airpods
max
[ __ ] done with apple like literally
this
this made me mad this story is like just
really interesting tech news which is
why we're talking about it here at the
morning toes
apple has announced their their new air
pods
macs which are wireless noise cancelling
headphones so
we know the air pods we know the air
pods noise cancelling now they have like
legit ass
headphones that cover your back to
square one cover your ears and do the
thing on top but they're bluetooth so
that's
like how they're different i'm just
saying and they're noise canceling and
they cost
549. they literally like shook up
our world forcing us to get airpods
removing the headphone jack from phones
like literally just like we all had no
choice but to get airpods and then we
got them we're like okay they're not so
bad it's actually kind of
they're actually [ __ ] sweet yeah now
we're going back we're reverting i don't
care if it's wireless
i'm just so done with apple just making
these decisions about how we're no
laterally
yeah about like how we're all gonna
behave technologically and like
we're just robots we just do what they
say like mark my words in six months
like i will have these and i will love
them because like
i am a [ __ ] slave
then literally it's always the second
they announced a new product
my product that's literally one version
earlier just stops working
yeah so that's the latest in tech news
like we're back to headphones
it we're back to headphones yeah i guess
they're all the technical terms
earphones
earbuds yeah no they look like bows or
yeah it's like
it's just i don't need them but just
literally play this but thanks for
offering play this episode for me
in two like four months when i have them
yep
yep yep um should we do our bachelorette
recap are you ready yeah i mean just get
we all we need is one minute
yeah i didn't watch um because i was
just like busy
but i did see some content online i
spoke to the snatcher she gave me like a
whole rundown
on the silliness of the lie detector
test how like you know zaxy cheated on
someone dot dot dot in the sixth grade
yeah and i just i'm actually upon
hearing the recap was so glad i didn't
waste my time no no like it was
so fruitless because the only oh no
she did have a rose ceremony and people
went home anyone notable went home or no
like not really but bennett went
like she sent bennett home when there
was a two on one but then at the end of
the night like he returned
so i mean i didn't need for him to
return
i can't fall from grace like for bennett
right i can't believe there's already
only seven guys left i'm really so
shocked
that blake moynes is still there talk
about a fall from grace yeah no i mean
when i think of him and asia i feel like
those are two people who have never
spoken
right so he just has sort of like skated
along
and didn't get in trouble and so he's
still around but i just don't see it for
him and
and it's just like he started who's
around noah
blake ben zeiss
ivan is that brendan still around who
had the one on one earlier
i like him um i think ed went home
finally
finally oh my god the cartoon like i was
so done with him
yeah and then there was one other guy
riley yes
he shared his um story with tasha and it
was um
because the lie detector test like
caught him on a lie
and so he it was worth explaining and he
he really opened up and he's
like he was what did you keep what was
the lie so he changed his name
because they asked him like we're going
to ask you some baseline questions like
what's your name and he gave his name
and then it was like
oh my god and he was explaining how he
was named after his dad and they had
like
like just his story about growing up how
they were so close and um
then he did some things that like he
didn't agree with and it was sort of
like creating this rift
with his mom and eventually he changed
his name so that he didn't have the same
name as
his dad yeah okay so like really not a
big deal no but just like something
you know he was sharing he was opening
up yeah also ben
had a one-on-one with tasha and he
opened up
even more about his past and his
struggles
um and it was really really like honest
and brave of him to do so like that he
had um
attempted suicide right and he was
talking about his sister was so cute
because he was saying his sister like
got him through everything but she
doesn't even know like how much she got
him through like
watching the show last night is probably
how she found out right what he even
struggled with right oh wow that's so
interesting yeah i feel like probably
more than ever
this for better and for us this is like
the most honest season of course like
everyone who comes on a tv show and just
everyone in life like has a story
yeah no one's life is perfect everyone
has been through hard things i just feel
like
this season more than ever like all of
that is like being brought to light
yeah but it also makes me sad because
obviously only one man will win i have
no idea who that will be i have no idea
like for the other six people except for
blake moins because he really still
hasn't opened up
so far so for the other you went from
like
literally loving like mine to like being
confused by him no i just like because
of how
excited i was about him it's like now he
let you down he really let me down
so these other five guys who are giving
everything that they have to tasia
leaving it all on the table being braver
than they've ever been before and
sharing like really personal things like
they're gonna go home four of them are
not five right
with nothing to show for it i mean i'm
sure they'll say like you know that it
definitely got them like
having their guard down and they'll go
into their next relationship more open
but it just like hurts me to think that
yeah but that always happens and it's no
one's fault
yeah i just feel like the stuff the guys
are opening up about this particular
season just seems like darker and
heavier
yeah we don't usually get this kind of
stuff from everyone
right but maybe that's just like a
testament to how tasha is just such
bringing it up like and really the when
she talks to the guys like
everything she says is just like so warm
and exactly what you would want to hear
and so i could understand just like
spilling your guts you know i
talked to her and i'm like literally
want to show her like everything inside
my soul yeah she is that type of person
by the way i definitely agree with that
yeah so maybe that's what maybe it's not
the guys it's
the person who's bringing it down in
them because i feel like claire
for the five minutes we had her was like
begging the guys to like
the guy she had just met to like
literally bear their soul
and just like tell him everything should
they've ever been
so there was so much like friction and
it was like tug of war like to get it
out
but you can't force it you can't force
it
yeah i feel like taisha just like has
this quality that like people just want
to share things with her
yeah and i think i like i feel like i
know people like that
yeah and that's just a really great
human quality
yes i agree it's like this warmth and
energy that like invites people in
yes i don't i don't think i would say
that i have that quality
um no but you have so many other like
fabulous qualities
amazing qualities like i'm so happy with
my qualities
my qualities are the best um then there
was the lie detector which i actually
always like a lie detector i'll never
forget on andy dorfman's season they
took a lie detector test and it caused
so much strife with her and josh marie
like after they got engaged can i ask
you a question
was the lie detector administrator the
guy from real housewives of beverly
hills
no it was jojo fletcher she
knows how to use a machine so she there
was like a laptop and
it was like a screensaver of like pulses
like literally it was like they didn't
have attack they put like a video from
youtube on full
legit and it had like the pulse lines
that are like from
a heart monitor there was no there was
no tech on like that we saw
and basically so they had all wires
hooked up and their little
youtube video playing and then there was
three lights on the side red
yellow green the person answering the
question like in front of the group and
then if it was a lie
went red if it was miffy i think about
yellow or was there only two i don't
know my perception was skewed
and then green was green okay because
what i wanted to say about the guy who
administered lisa vanderpump's
lie detector test in like the years he's
like the go-to
yeah i've seen him on david dobrik's
youtube channel i've seen him all over
youtubers channels
and that's what kyle and the girls were
saying like this guy's like an actor
and they sounded crazy but now like
seeing his career as like the go-to
youtube lie detector
there's definitely something like shitty
about him the go-to um
just reality tv lie detector guy where
did you see him
i i saw after the fact like that he had
been on other shows yeah now like i know
his face
yeah and that was a shady lie detector
test for sure
i mean there was nothing shadier than
the one administered by jojo fletcher
but so she's still the host do they say
how much longer she's gonna be there for
no she didn't but she was doing like a
great job it was always just like fun to
see her
yeah honestly like i'm into like the
shake up and energy like
host wise yeah but it did feel like the
campers were at camp and the counselors
were gone no the
yeah the campers are running the camp
yeah they let like a jc watch the bunk
but things are going haywire that's what
it felt like just saying
um okay so i'll get back on watching
last week i mean no rush
no i know i'm just like i feel like you
could skip one more week if you needed
to and then come back for hometowns
yeah because like still things are so
unclear if i had to place a bet about
who i think would win
i'm gonna say zack c you would
yeah okay she gives everyone so much
love i'm like so unclear on who the
front runner is
maybe brendan but like jimmy kimmel
guess
does he i don't know this whole season
has been i just want to say like jimmy
kimmel is like you know like 30 for 30
on guessing
um bachelorette winners and it's like
yeah no doubt you work for abc like they
obviously give you the winner
no but i feel like they actually don't
because that would be like a clear
spoiler i just don't know how you could
literally know every single one after
the first episode like yeah
apparently his wife helps and she's like
that's just a talent of hers it's just
like tasha
is like super warm and you want to spill
your guts like jimmy kimmel's wife can
pick bachelorette one
tasha's first impression rose guy went
home last night right spencer yes so
it's like how would anyone have guessed
let's say zach c wins like how would
anyone
guess that i don't know based on the
conversations from the first night it's
just confusing
who wins i don't know but he cheated on
someone in the sixth grade
i know and by the way did you mar when i
when margo the snatcher gave me her full
recap she told me that she thought that
that was a lie
wow like he got caught on the line he
just like made something up she said
what she said
she said what she said she doesn't hold
back and which is why the snatcher
is an amazing award-winning podcast that
you should listen to if you want more
bachelor tea and also like she knows
everything about the bachelor world like
who's doing what on tick tock
is embarrassing themselves and you know
who's embarrassing themselves and i and
i hate to say it because i've been
seeing him a lot on tick tock
and it's not that the content's bad it's
just like there's something about
joining tick tock before your season's
over that just gives me like a really
bad vibe and it's been
oh yeah so unfortunately damn well if
you want more information
like that head to the snatcher because
she knows all
um now for our dear toasters everyone's
been waiting for we have two
new gear toaster submissions and then i
will give you our update and our deer
toasters is brought to you by legacy box
the most brilliant product i can't
believe i didn't think of it myself a
safe and affordable way to digitally
preserve
all your home movies and photos that are
currently trapped on dated formats like
vhs
or film this is first of all a great
thing to get someone for the holiday
season
or just like for yourself we for years
had like
boxes and like bins of just like vhs
cassettes and like who the hell knows
how to do that
legacy box is the most genius service on
the planet you can reclaim all the
priceless footage
you haven't been able to see in years
it's so simple the service user kit to
safely send the moments you want to
preserve
their team will create a digital archive
by hand then you'll receive your new
copies
stored on the cloud a thumb drive or dvd
you have to choose
along with all the original media that
you sent them so you get the original
stuff back but then you get it
digitally preserved on a thumb drive or
a dvd
with their tracking system you can
monitor every step of the process so you
always know your originals
are being taken care of over the past 10
years legacy box has helped close to 1
million families restore
and protect their most cherished
memories and right now they're offering
sixty percent off
so you can have everything preserved at
once for a fraction of the regular price
once you have these digital versions you
can relax knowing that they'll be
secured for generations
that's so true i feel like boxes of like
vhs is like piling up it's just like
like you you feel like you're never
going to be able to see that stuff again
and like you almost part ways with it
emotionally
but but to see it bring brought back to
life is crazy like getting your hands
and actually turning on those videos is
so crazy
and if you're like similar age to us
like your whole life was like a
camcorder
growing up and it's just crazy to see so
it's really like such a nice gift
to get for your parents or like someone
you love in your family it's something
you can order in minutes and enjoy
forever
it is the best deal of the year so we
have the code for you guys go to
legacybox.com
slash toast and take advantage of this
limited time offer and get 60
off the exclusive offer won't last long
so order their kit now and send it
whenever you're ready so
just because you order the kit doesn't
mean you have to send it in now but if
you want to get the 60
off order the kit now and send it in
when you're ready it's a sale to
remember
go to legacy box dot com toast and save
60 while supplies last
okay dear toasters our advice segment if
you ever want to write in the email is
dear toasters
gmail.com we always keep it anonymous
we'll never
write you out so here we go hi claudia
and jackie i need some advice on a
situation with my fiance
about a few months ago i realized that
my fiance had begun smoking weed
i can smell it on him occasionally and i
found a few empty tubes lying around
we live in california so it's legal i
have a feeling he does not want me to
know because he doesn't think i would
approve
however this isn't the case i really
don't care either way i have no interest
in smoking with him but i could care
less if he does what i don't like is the
fact that he hides it
i kept telling myself that eventually he
would tell me or that i would end up
catching him
we live on an acre of property so there
are places he can hide he will randomly
tell me that he needs to go to our shop
to turn off the lights
in the greenhouse which i know is not
true then he comes back to the house
smelling
i hate confrontation and just the
thought of randomly bringing it up
gives me so much anxiety what should i
do is there an easier way that i can
bring it up with it where it's not so
awkward
please help thank you and you seem cool
i just have to say like
yeah i will give you advice but you seem
like a cool gal i like you i feel like
you just need to randomly bring it up
you know like it's weird that he's
hiding it from you
and if i'm sure it's like a source of
anxiety for him that he feels need to
hide it from you i don't know why he
does but like for him to know that you
don't care
would just i feel like take a weight off
of him and bring you guys closer
together
yeah um so on the one hand it's like you
don't need to sit him down and have a
serious conversation even though like
the part about him sneaking around just
makes him like oh he's sneaky
he's capable of sneaking right that's
always like telling of other behaviors
which like i hate to be like
so pessimistic it also seems like he's
not very good at it right so if
something was going on you would know
right and it's good like it's good to
know that your man's like not good at
being sneaky yeah and i just like really
appreciate
your kind of mature view like i hate
girls who are like
mad when their boyfriends smoke pot like
11 years old like
let him he's an adult do whatever he
wants he can be doing meth like who
cares it's [ __ ] pot like it's not a
big deal
yeah i just hate when people are like so
protective so i
you sound cool i just want to say like
yeah so i think um there's two ways you
could
go about it like one he comes in from
the greenhouse you're sitting there lamp
overhead
where have you been yeah you that would
be making it weird just come in and be
like why you being such a freak i know
you're smoking pot you could do it in
the house
as long as you do it in the house honey
right or you could like go out
get a j bring it home be like hey let's
have a night together like smoking oh no
that's
that's too much acting when you have to
act and like literally put a script
together just to confront someone like
no
sometimes like you know what when you
prepare it pays off just don't make it
weird just be like he comes in the house
and like what are you doing like
you're smoking pot in the house like
what am i your mom like sit down smoke
pot like
i don't care why are you hiding that
[ __ ] for me yeah but i do think like if
i don't want to like give you any cause
for concern but the fact that he's
hiding it like is a little concerning
yeah so it does require a conversation
of like why do you feel like you need to
hide it
what else are you hiding sir no no not
what else are you hiding
but why why are you hiding this from me
like did i ever say something that would
make you think that i wouldn't be okay
with this that's true
that's true you know but that's like so
passive aggressive like is it me no
no but definitely just like talk about
it like
yeah also you live on an acre that
sounds really nice in california can we
come
i know that literally sounds like also
greenhouse yeah so you're into plans
like what's the time
maybe he's growing his own oh that's the
thing he could be hiding it because it's
that's not what he's hiding
it's a bigger thing he's running this
whole industry out of your greenhouse
it's weeds
it's weeds the tv show like he's one of
the biggest drug dealers
in california right and then still it's
like why wouldn't he bring you into it
maybe he doesn't want to share the
profits i don't know oh that's shady
because then he would like make you sign
a prenup and [ __ ] that's like so hurtful
that's so hurtful like what well you
don't think i'm good enough like to
share in the profits
empire that's not cool that's not cool
so i do
i do think he could be hiding a little
more than just like the hobby
maybe a booming not to give you a pit
congratulations
yeah i mean how are you paying for that
acre of land someone's got to pay the
bills
um sorry to give you a pit but talk to
your boyfriend no
beyonce i think you're gonna find like a
pot of gold at the end of this rainbow
yeah no like a liter like a drug empire
yeah and it's california so it's leaving
so it's totally legal
okay next up your toasters long story
short sure
i spend thanksgiving with my boyfriend's
family for the first time i was nervous
but couldn't travel to see my own family
so i sucked it up and took on the
daunting task of attending thanksgiving
dinner with my boyfriend
of one month i met the fam
things were going to be great to the
girl you used to be
we sit down for dinner and my
boyfriend's dad leads the table in
prayer
which is all dandy until their tradition
of having a moment of silence to reflect
on what we're grateful for
i want you to picture the quietest of
quiet silences
painfully silent and painfully long the
perfect time
the perfect time for my stomach to start
swirling
i started squirming in the hopes of
keeping the inevitable from happening
i started praying that my boyfriend's
dad would finally say amen and the awful
silence would end my prayers went
unanswered
during the moment of silence i ripped no
no
she literally spelled i literally ripped
the fattest
fart p-h-a-t-t that is far it was loud
it was rotten and it lingered stop
you're single goodbye
the fart encourages get unhinged try
again get some gasoline
fart encourage the dad to start let me
finish because i've heard everything i
need to fart and i heard everything
the fart encouraged the dad to finally
say amen and when everyone looked up i
was obviously blushing and the culprit
i shut down for the rest of the night
due to embarrassment i'm sure they think
i'm a [ __ ] now
my boyfriend kept asking if i was okay
and my social skills left me to die
then you weren't okay what the [ __ ] do i
do my boyfriend's family thinks i'm a
[ __ ] now my boyfriend thinks something
is wrong right and i can't bring myself
i can't bring my because she said she
was like she's shut down after the fart
like she just didn't talk to anyone
because like she was so embarrassed
so she said i can't bring myself to tell
the truth that i ripped ass and
they didn't hear it they did but like i
don't think they know for sure that it
was her
so she said i can't bring myself to tell
the truth that i ripped ass on my
boyfriend's family thanksgiving dinner
do i tell the truth i can't stop acting
weird and i'm the worst liar
honestly this relationship this
relationship is so short i would
honestly just cut the rest cut your
losses
start again yeah i'm i'm i don't know
how you come back from this like i don't
know
how you would want to like start the
work of repairing
you know what this fart has broken like
yeah i just i wouldn't
i couldn't be too much damage has been
done and you really don't have that much
to lose with this guy of one month like
and there's so many other men out there
and honestly you seem hilarious
so just like it's so not worth trying to
fix yeah you know what like i feel like
maybe your stomach that was your gut
trying to tell you something literally
trying to ruin this relationship for you
yeah because something's not right i
think you need to just
take theo if you were talking to a
therapist like you could really feel
like
maybe your subconscious like sabotage
this relationship on purpose because you
knew it wasn't the right relationship
for you
right you should thank that fart for
showing you the true path and just
get out yeah i i really think
cut and run yeah cut your losses i just
wouldn't want to live
like my life with people who like knew
what i did
yeah because like let's say you guys get
married like this is your family like
you're always like
your first impression will always be
where you farted and it's like
you know what you can rewrite the story
yeah it's not too late to rewrite your
own story you're so right just get out
of this relationship
and find a new man yeah but you are
saying there's a chance they don't know
it was you
yeah that was the confusing part was
like do they know it was you or did they
not know it was you
also are you okay like to fart before
dinner like that yeah you haven't eaten
yet so like why is your stomach swirling
so bad that sounds like maybe some ibs
yeah i would also checked out i would
bring up your boy break up with your
boyfriend and then immediately head to
the doctor head to a gastroenterologist
now it's time for our law firm basement
update
so to recap a girl had written in she's
a lawyer
she works at a firm where like these two
brothers are cousins or partners and one
of them is like kind of weird
and she noticed that like he was
literally like taking jugs of water and
like buckets and like
storing them in the office basement like
sheltering for something it was all very
weird
like he wasn't stealing them he was like
hunkering and bunkering down yeah his
name was bob but he was just freaky as
[ __ ]
yeah so she has wrote in claudia and
jackie
it's been two years
and the mystery keeps getting weirder oh
no we're not gonna get answers
bob the weird co-worker who stored all
the cases of water and buckets and
sealant remember it was like that weird
materials in our law firm basement was
told by our boss two years ago to remove
all those item items from the basement
he removed them provided no explanation
and we figured the mystery would go
unsolved
six months after that in march of 2019
bob
hastily moves himself and his family to
florida
our firm is in the midwest bob remains
on the firm's payroll but he literally
has no duties
reminder do you unlike the girl from
before who had a lot of duties
they big duty
okay that's what the family will say
about you you don't
get the [ __ ] butt of the joke the
whole time
okay so bob remains on the firm's
payroll but he literally has
no duties
reminder bob is the boss's brother we
all assume it's just nepotism but the
two had a huge falling out
so some of us think that maybe it's not
nepotism so our boss joe like the
unweird brother lives two hours away
from the law firm headquarters
he's never in the office he works
remotely most of the time he comes to
the headquarters about once every two
months or so
i've caught him sneaking down to the
basement during the early morning hours
like in the eight o'clock hour in the
late hours like five or six what the
[ __ ]
no one goes in the basement it's old
files and old office furniture literally
no one has a valid reason to go down
there
joe sneaks to the basement every time he
comes up to the headquarters no one is
with him so it's not a rendezvous he
literally goes in the basement alone
every time he comes to the headquarters
he doesn't know that i've noticed
but i've been watching what the [ __ ] is
in this basement i've personally
searched it and found
nothing do i need to go pull insulation
off the walls and search harder
something is definitely down there that
is of great importance this has been
going on for two whole years advice
help at this point i need to be on
unsolved mysteries thank you
wow not only did we get literally no it
got
more confusing because joe is like the
normal
boss so like bob was always weird so you
could always chalk it up to just like
bob being weird
yeah but now i think you have to
you got to head down to the basement
after hours get a flashlight and like
really search
no you have to follow him into the
basement like see what he is doing and
then when he turns around like literally
flashlight in the eye i'd be like what's
going on
no no like just or if you know what time
he's coming to the office get to the
basement before him
then watch to see where he goes in the
basement what area
you don't have to like see exactly what
he's doing but then when he leaves you
can go back to that area the reason for
being in the basement
he can't see you okay okay hide in
shadows but it's like how was any how
are you getting any legal work done in
your office like if all you're doing is
oh my gosh
you're literally like watching all your
co-workers like schedules like when they
go to the bathroom when they go to the
basement where they live if they're on
the payroll it's like do you get any
work done in this law firm
no maybe this is selena and barnes
celino and mom
you know they're just silly no now i
know barnes passed away i know
in a tragic plane crash it's so sad and
i just think it's kind of crazy that
selena like a month later like gave new
commercials
new logo who dis just celino he couldn't
have kept the legacy of barnes
that's one rebrand i can't get behind
that's true you love a rebrand i do
but not at the expense so how does the
song go now in the comments
lino and celino injury attorneys
say 888 888
don't wait what's your favorite like
commercial jingle i mean besides for
carmel
fine after carmel i mean there's so many
to 300 empire today
stanley steemer [ __ ] heart oh
[Music]
[Music]
you know what i love liberty liberty
liberty
liberty yeah i always call snitch i'm
like snitchery snitchery
snitcher of course there's always the
iconic i
was working for an hourly wage i went to
high
school didn't do great still i gotta
make more cash
more education is what i'm looking at
when i get a degree
i will make a bigger salary so now i've
got to see
which college is right for me i went on
the internet
and found education connection i took
some pretext
to find out my direction sort of breath
i'm taking my classes online getting my
degree on my own
time education connection match me with
the right college for free
get connected for free free with
education connection get connected
for free for free with education can
that's
probably the best i mean it just i think
i threw my back out
yeah slaps also some of the lipids
some of the nationwide commercials with
like country singers are pretty good
oh yeah nationwide is on your side
yeah with like brad paisley yeah it's
all right i don't know it's kind of
basic like
it's a little basic yeah i mean they
just don't make them like they used to
education connection no they really
don't i just feel like there should be
more
people investing time and money into
commercial jingles because they stick
with you and i know i'm dialing seven
that's all but that's what i know
couldn't agree more i'm actually dialing
six but
but see like there's something for
everyone yeah um and that's our show you
guys
yeah anything else you want to say
before we wrap up no a new episode of
the red head shops tomorrow it is so
good and if if you're looking for some
premium content the redheads are here
for you we always are and we always will
be so
also new we're going to announce the
next book that is a snitch's choice and
i've already been seeing some buzz about
this book in the redheads um
facebook page yeah so i think everyone's
going to be really excited about it
i want to spoil it but i won't oh
speaking of books while i'm here i mean
i might as well check out my book it
comes out january 26
2021 it is called girl then job the
crazy beautiful life of an instagram
thirst monster
the pre-order is now available if you
want to get the e-book so if you want to
get it on kindle
or the audiobook you want to get it on
audible or just a hardcover book from
amazon barnes and noble
or indie book stores around the country
if you go to girlsnowjob.combook you can
find all the links
to places you can purchase and i would
really appreciate the pre-order support
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the monday morning
show where we deliver the fastback
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube if
you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cat box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning chosen leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
have an amazing hump day we'll see you
tomorrow for the second half of the week
we're almost done you guys yes goodbye
[Music]
goodbye